hire eject nation I'm Greg Alba what's
your name
Kelly Russa what's yours daniela blog
Ksenia Leblanc brand new to the channel
kelly you've already got enough phrase
alright let's just keep all the hype
train I can stand here anyway guys if
you want them to come back already make
sure it's not smelled this way Xenia
Leblanc like Matthew LeBlanc yeah no
that's awesome
verily No ah are you doing and Kelly
Russo follow her at Kelly Russo she
doesn't follow me yet I haven't earned
that privilege that is not true we're
gonna transition now who do this we're
gonna watch a movie trailer for I think
it's a youtube original animated movie I
think I could be completely wrong about
that it's called spies in disguise the
voice talents of I believe Will Smith
and Tom Holland from spider-man yeah
we're gonna do it okay you guys excited
I'm very
[Music]
identity scan initiated
[Music]
let the beat drop
[Music]
[Music]
why it worked
[Music]
look at you I can see my butt this movie
has Deadshot spider-man and nebula all
in one movie pigeons in here I was kind
of confused is that just a bit that
happened or the plot of the movie for so
long I think it's cute I think it's a
Jew or lovely it looks so adorable you
know the the animation style kinda
reminds me of The Incredibles films I
thought it was going to be a mystery
yeah like black incredible man yeah yeah
yeah he did we know the kind of guy
Kelly likes right we don't make this
awkward yeah yeah this actually looks
really funny oftentimes when something
is animated that is not Pixar or not
DreamWorks you know anything for like
Disney or something I tend to have this
mindset of is this gonna be any good I
heard this got delayed for some reason
but then looking at this this the
quality of it look really looks on par
and Will Smith is so freakin funny and I
feel like we don't see him do enough
comedies anymore and he's actually been
back at doing his own YouTube channel a
lot lately where are you gonna see a lot
of that Will Smith Blair just hearing
his voice here like that whole pigeon
bit you're just like that's the Will
Smith comic timing that I want to see
more of again to have the voiced ounce
of Tom Holland who's hilarious the
spider-man I versus really this is gonna
be one really funny ass fella I think
it's really cool I'm super excited about
it
kind of have the same thing you said
about the Disney thing so I'm excited
yeah is it gonna be as cool is it gonna
be as fun but I think it's really
awesome the characters all it's kind of
like Shrek and the Shrek character the
my favorite the person boots no donkey
donkey don't you think kind of because
it does not spit so it's just I think
it's good what I'm hoping for is that
you get a lot more of the weirdness of
it because the first half of the trailer
was just like James Bond style which
feels like The Incredibles or because
the Incredibles already has that spy
element to it and the animation does
look like The Incredibles and then you
get this weird bit at the end about the
pigeons so I'm actually hoping that we
watch this movie that it actually has
all this like weirdness through because
I like weird stuff I like saying eNOS
and I like when they take advantage of
these action spy elements and animation
because you can do blueseed live-action
spy films all the time when you do an
animated version you give you all crazy
like when he's like flying with the suit
and let that forms from like a tuxedo I
think that's something really cool and
very inventive well I don't know what
other animated films this company has
done but this actually looks really
enticing it's really good is the company
again I think it's cut blue sky oh yeah
yeah yeah what have they done you're
smart Ksenia this is your chance blue
sky you did great I just wanted to say
great job amazing
I approve we jump cut here because we
just we I can say any I do a little
Google search yeah and what is blue sky
protections me it did I say Ice Age yes
and that animation style now seems
incredibly reminiscent I don't know I
mean I feel like sometimes their films
are there your humor can be very low
brow and not all that entertaining but I
have a lot of faith that the comedy here
will probably hit home really good here
looks funny yeah I'm excited
I feel like we just repeated ourselves a
bunch of time saying how it's cute and
whenever you have the character like you
have animal characters pop up and they
always have like cute eyes and they
create them with such cute like likable
sort of quality I feel like that always
makes you want to say like so cute it's
gonna be so lovely yeah they're good
with that apparently the squirrel was
lovely there you go there you go so cute
thank you
it's like the cute I'm gonna make fun of
Greg really fast so he said that the zoo
was inventive a flying squirrel is the
same you know I'm talking about having a
tuxedo go into it okay oh yeah but I
think that's a nature I don't try to
make fun of me Kelly
III got that handled on myself all the
time already all right sorry sorry you
bring your friend here I'm gonna make
sure she looks good and I'm gonna make
fun of you that's just the way it works
Winnie and really quick I want to give a
page from the day shout-out to a man
named Curt Anderson Curt Anderson is a
guy who he's always traveling the world
yeah your name means traveler yeah hey
you guys should link up sometime just
because of that one fact right there and
Curt is someone who I could actually
believe could be a spy he's pledged to
our patreon former war tier that gives
him access to certain things that he
doesn't ever seem to really participate
in so I wonder if he's just kind of
doing it because he's trying to find out
something about us I wonder if he's even
really named Curt you seem like a dude
when I go to your Instagram you're
always exploring the world that why how
where do you get these funds to go
around the world did you have a
consistent job I don't know who you are
or what you do but I want to let you
know that it's okay if you keep pledging
to our patreon appreciate that very much
buddy anyway you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell Ksenia you could check out her matt
LeBlanc and surround page as soon as you
can and Kelly Russo is the third Russo
brother go check out her
as soon as you can and we'll talk with
you guys soon